eine frage die uns in dieser sendung in
der heute show traditionell umtreibt
lautet bekanntlich wie geht's eigentlich
der fdp die liberalen hatten gerade
bundesparteitag in berlin und ja
angesichts von umfragewerten ganz knapp
über fünf prozent wäre das schon eine
prima gelegenheit gewesen für
nachdenkliche töne vom vorsitzenden
wenn nicht sogar für regelrechte
selbstkritik stattdessen setzt lindner
lieber auf attacke wird sie nicht
überraschen er sagt die fdp will
nächstes jahr regieren was mein
parteivorsitz ist anders an das ziel
unmittelbar gebunden dass sich die fdp
in die regierung führen will
verstehen sie was das heißt wenn die fdp
nächstes jahr nicht in der regierung
landet muss hören lindner eine anschluss
verwendung gefunden werden noch sitzt
allerdings sehr fest im sattel und zwar
trotz klimaschutz den profis überlassen
trotz kemmerich debakel in thüringen und
natürlich trotz jamaika das ewige
jamaika kein interview kommt aus ohne
jamaika natürlichen lachen erkennt man
das trauma ist ein traum deswegen wollen
sie unbedingt regieren und zwar egal mit
wem
zur not sogar mit der spd so verzweifelt
sind die inzwischen ja natürlich fordert
die fdp auch ein paar vernünftige sachen
wie zum beispiel kostenlose laptops für
arme kinder gute idee aber der rest es
im wesentlichen schlanker staat steuern
runter die klassiker halt außerdem
laufen ihn nach wie vor die frauen weg
inzwischen nur noch 21 prozent
frauenanteil
da muss was passieren ja entscheidende
moment etwas muss passiert wobei
natürlich natürlich können auch ältere
männer zukunftsfragen beantworten die
fdp schließlich eine nach vorne
gerichtete hochmoderne partei und reich
hier ein ganz wichtig aktueller clip die
gesamtpartei erzielte einen beachtlichen
jahresüberschuss von über 8 millionen
d-mark
sie steigerte damit wir ein vermögen von
7 24 millionen
auf 15,58 5 millionen thema gut in euro
ist das natürlich nur die hälfte von
reich seit der gar nicht schatzmeister
solms auf dem parteitag in berlin viel
zu früh in rente geschickt ansonsten
wird christian lindner aktuell heftig
kritisiert haben sie möglicherweise
verfolgt für die art wie er die von ihm
geführte generalsekretär in linda
teuteberg verabschiedet hat nämlich mit
einem leicht ranzigen herrenwitz rainer
brüderle gefällt das wobei die
ultimative demütigung war ja dass er
frau teuteberg als ersatz ernsthaft den
job der fdp ostbeauftragten angeboten
hat die fdp gibt es überhaupt nicht im
osten wollte die länder nicht komisch
wollte sie nicht es ist aber auch
schwierig mitarbeitern elegant zu
kündigen eine uralte kunst die nur noch
ganz wenige gut beherrschen
herzlich willkommen zu
untergebene feiern mit stil mit freiherr
albrecht von und zu humboldt
[Musik]
albrecht humboldt ja stilvoll anderer
leute karrieren beenden wie geht das
da hat sich leider über die jahre eine
unnötige verweichlichung eingeschlichen
ich sage immer gutes feuern geht nur mit
gesunder härte können nicht viel aber
wie der lindner die teuteberg abgesägt
hat war für sie jetzt okay vom härtegrad
ja gut es geht natürlich immer noch
härter gremium hat in nordkorea seinen
onkel vorne haubitze gebunden aber das
ist arbeitsrechtlich in deutschland
schwierig also nie hat das ganz gut
gefallen wie der lindener das gelöst hat
mit der kleinen teuteberg es ist ja auch
eine angespannte situation auf so einem
parteitag du weißt nicht fängt die
gleich an zu heulen oder macht die szene
dann lockt hast du das halt auf mit
einem witz ich denke gerne daran dass
wir in den vergangenen 15 monaten
ungefähr 300 mal ich hab mal so grob
überschlagen
ungefähr 300 mal den tag zusammen
begonnen haben ich spreche über unser
tägliches morgendliches telefonat zur
politischen lage nicht was jetzt denkt
man denkt den beiden hätten
der knick das superding ach das ist so
schade dass die teuteberg da so gequält
guckt kinder
man muss doch auch mal ein bisschen über
sich selbst lachen könnten ja also wenn
ich eine frau raus käme die erst vor
einem jahr mit 93 von meiner partei
gewählt wurde muss sich der doch nicht
noch einen blöden pimmel witz
hinterherrufen humor polizei
es ist ihm halt spontan eingefallen dem
chrissi weil er ein kreativer typ ist
wirklich spontan eingefallen hier
lindner 2017
ich bin heute morgen wach geworden mit
claudia roth
also ich habe gesagt mit nicht nehmen
also ich find den beim zweiten war sogar
noch witzig und hängte er hat mit
claudia roth also jetzt mal ernsthaft
lindlar musste die teuteberg feuern
seine fdp setzt jetzt wieder auf
wirtschaftsthemen da musste rechnen
können so wie der neue generalsekretär
eins und eins ist eins und nicht frei
war wahrscheinlich auch im witz ach da
fällt mir ein herum wollen die heute
show setzt tatsächlich bald verstärkt
auf ganz andere themen neue inhaltliche
schwerpunkt und so sehr ich sie
persönlich stelle war
gesunde härte du bist raus verpiss dich
sehr gern vielen dank albrecht humboldt
inzwischen gehört auch zur wahrheit
bedauert händler übrigens seinen
teuteberg spruch natürlicher
koalitionspartner der fdp bleibt derweil
logischerweise die gute alte cdu die in
rund zwei monaten über den parteivorsitz
entscheidet und damit wohl über unseren
nächsten bundeskanzler ist einer von den
dreien ihr soll es werden also es sei
denn söder sagt verfahrenstechnischen
ich mach's doch aktuell ist es ein
dreikampf der bizarrerweise medial so
gar nicht stattfindet außer bei uns zdf
spezial
ja was ist denn hier los das rennen um
den cdu vorsitz interessiert keine sau
deutschland was ist denn los mit dir du
interessierst dich doch sonst für jeden
scheiß die cdu entscheidet über den
kommenden kanzler bei einer wahl die die
ganze vielfalt unserer nation abbildet
ein alter mann aus dem sauerland einen
mittelalter mann aus dem rheinland und
ein kleiner mann aus aachen heißt unser
nächster häuptling kommt in jedem fall
aus nrw der sympathischen industrie
brache in der mitte europas kein
ostdeutscher keine frau nicht mal ein
hesse trübt das bild und haben sie das
gelesen kandidat laschet stammt von karl
dem großen ab ich hätte eher auf louis
de funes getippt und eins ist klar der
armin kann wahlkampf interessiert das
eigentlich keine mehr
wie schon das hat er selbst til
schweiger nicht schlechter spielen
können
ich lege mich heute schon fest laschet
wird nicht und fritze märz wird auch
nicht die kahle fichte aus dem sauerland
hat sich gerade selber aus dem rennen
gekickt erst beleidigt der arbeitsscheue
kurzarbeiter und dann der körper hier
hätten sie vorbehalte wenn heute ein
schwuler bundeskanzler würde über über
die frage der sexuellen orientierung
das geht die öffentlichkeit nichts an
solange sich das im rahmen der gesetze
bewegt und so lange es nicht kinder
betrifft
ich habe mal gehört er hat nicht mal was
gegen heteros obwohl das natürlich echt
ne ziemliche ferkel eis unter uns gesagt
märz ist raus der wahre favorit für den
cdu-vorsitz ist diese lichtgestalt aus
der kaffee werbung
für so einen schönen mann macht sogar
friedrich merz eine ausnahme norbert
clooney röttgen ein echtes kanzler
gesicht sogar mit haaren darüber nicht
lachen so was entscheidet war große
kanzler hatten immer schöne haare helmut
schmidt ein scheitl wie in beton
gegossen oder gerd schröder der übrigens
bis heute nicht färbt also wrote können
wird feierabend und nächste woche bei
zdf spezial sensation gentest beweist
markus söder stammt von winnetou ab ich
habe gesprochen
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
nike dallas ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da